[Music]
if our time with the scp foundation has
taught us anything it's that books are
evil and not to be trusted this is why
right now you're doing the right thing
and watching some nice wholesome youtube
videos rather than potentially exposing
your delicate mind to the devilry of the
written word think we're over
exaggerating here
that's how they get you sure you could
pick up a book right now and give it a
read but what if it was
scp-592 the inaccurate history book
where just reading beyond a certain
point will drive you mad and start to
inflict potentially deadly wounds caused
by a nightmarish retroactively altered
past or what if you decided you wanted
to read some slightly more niche
historical subjects and picked up a
vintage copy of a chronicle of the devas
not knowing that this is also an
incomplete chronicle classified as
scp-140 you get a paper cut on one of
those aging yellow pages and boom you're
suddenly forced into slavery in a day
vibe labor camp maybe that rightly
scared you off of history you want to do
something a little more scientific so
you grab a copy of scp-1025
the encyclopedia of common diseases next
thing you know agents of the cdc are
surrounding you wearing hazmat suits and
setting up a secure quarantine tent
because they think you have a rare
strain of super mega ebola not even some
nice escapist fantasy is safe you pick
up a copy of scp-1230 a hero is born to
have a magical fantasy adventure in your
dreams but then when you wake up you've
lost all your lust for life because it
just can't measure up to the fantasy and
don't even get us started on scp-3512
an anomalous book of pickup artist tips
called the more you know a pickup
artist's guide sure it may have a
forward by snoop dogg himself and it may
be less dangerous to read than the other
books here but considering it's
ultimately a book of fifthist rituals
designed to help you mind control women
for romantic purposes you're probably a
horrible person if you want a copy so
we're all on the same page now books are
evil they're best to be avoided at all
costs and what is a catalog or magazine
but a very thin book right so they're
evil light you cannot trust them under
any circumstances that's why when
professor snyder got a strange new
magazine delivered directly into his
mailbox it didn't take long for him to
smell a rat and take it down to his
local scp foundation containment site
for some preliminary tests the magazines
cover red the official scp sales catalog
already this was weird enough the scp
foundation doesn't produce any kind of
sales catalog that's more marshall
carter and dark's modus operandi but
this catalog had dr jack bright on the
cover smiling and holding
scp-066 the living ball of yarn known as
eric's toy like he was overjoyed with it
when professor snyder showed the cover
to dr bright himself he said that it
might just be some high quality
photoshop because he never took a photo
like that the cover also bores slogans
like our best issue ever and hundreds of
bargains and professor snyder soon found
that both of these bizarre slogans were
true in a manner of speaking the inside
of the catalog contained comprehensive
records of almost every scp recorded on
the database complete with photos and
descriptions though rather than the
sterile scientific depictions typical of
an scp foundation document these
descriptions were written like pepe
sales copy aimed at selling off the
products in question mortified by the
potential security breach he was holding
professor snyder decided to take a look
through the catalog and assess the
damage flicking between the pages both
dazzled and terrified by just how deep
this thing went item 063 the world's
greatest toth brush don't let the typo
fool you this toothbrush is out of this
world no toothpaste needed just gently
scrub your teeth and like magic all that
nasty plaque is completely obliterated
and for those ground in countertop
stains look no further than the world's
greatest top brush available in blue
pink and green
scp-063 of course being a toothbrush
capable of completely expunging matter
from existence with its anomalous
bristles item 123 contained miniature
black hole back in stock after so many
requests this black hole is guaranteed
to spaghettify anything you throw at it
great for science projects and parties
and what's a better way to say i love
you than with the gift of a contained
miniature black hole order now while
supplies last warning contain small
parts it goes without saying why ever
giving the public access to a dangerous
and unstable contained black hole would
be a disaster of a truly cosmic
magnitude item 244 ice fog jar why waste
electric bill money on expensive
refrigerators this jar will turn an
enclosed space of any size into your own
private meat locker freeze whatever you
want just pop off the lid and watch it
go oh boy engaging with scp-244 is an
extremely risky business once the fog
from the jar has reduced the ambient
temperature of the room significantly it
runs the risk of bringing in scp-244-2
a deadly gaseous entity that can kill
people with an instant flash freezing
effect item 340 insanity candy a truly
maddening prank trick your friends into
eating these covert candies and watch
them literally go out of their minds
available in five packs professor snyder
winced at the memories this one brought
on
scp-340 now a deadly kind of virus had
once been a particularly lethal packet
of m ms capable of inducing various
types of severe mental illness in its
victims this was no prank unless you
happen to be an extreme sadist with no
regard for human life and happiness like
all the prank channels that have since
been wiped from youtube item 447 ball of
green slime what can you do with it what
can't you do with it use it as a
lubricant top off your gas tank style
your hair or even dress up your salads
and sundaes the possibilities are
endless now available in blue warning do
not apply to dead bodies professor
snyder gulped and shuddered the less
said about that the better item 500
panacea got ebola hiv cancer athlete's
foot this pill cures them all normality
is too incurable out of stock this one
was equal parts relieving and surprising
believing because at least this
particularly rare and powerful item was
out of stock and when it was in stock
demanded a six-figure payment per pill
surprised by the fact anyone outside the
foundation knew about the panacea and
wasn't bashing down their doors to get
it item 551 impossible puzzle throw out
your rubik's cube and put down that
crossword this is the puzzle to end all
puzzles no one in history has ever
completed it can you hours of fun this
mind-shattering jigsaw puzzle was an
incredibly dangerous thing to market as
a mere toy especially considering some
of its victims lost their minds while
attempting to solve it but professor
snyder could only brace himself turning
page after page because things were
about to get a whole lot worse in the
official scp sales catalog item 173 the
sculpture spice up your living room with
this unique decoration the ultimate
conversation piece that you will
literally never want to stop looking at
will draw the eye of all of your most
distinguished guests item035 the
possessive mask for those with a
theatrical spirit this mask is a perfect
way to hide that ugly mug while also
putting some fascinating new ideas in
your head this mask really speaks to you
and you'll find that after wearing it
for a while you'll lose a lot of weight
too item 1981 ronald reagan caught up
while talking are you a big fan of
analog horror and one of the few people
who still own a working vcr do you have
a real disdain for the late ex-president
ronald reagan then you'll love this
classic taping of one of his iconic
speeches no spoilers item 5000 the suit
are you looking for the latest word in
anomalous fashion that can be
ostentatious or very very discreet
you'll love this total exclusion suit
it'll do everything you need and more
especially when it feels like the world
is going crazy around you item055 the
anti-meme it isn't a sphere
ah i'm sorry what were we trying to sell
you here again item 2000 deus ex machina
for when you or the entire world just
needs a fresh start you can't go wrong
with this unique big ticket item great
for people who love mountain hikes too
item 914 the clockworks improve the
people and possessions in your life in
fun and unexpected ways or grind them
down into dust it's all up to you we
don't care what you do with it as long
as you pay for it item 662 the butler's
handbell just ring the bell and put your
feet up mr deeds the world's finest
butler will do anything and everything
you want within reason he's well dressed
polite and endlessly professional what
more could you want item 847 the
mannequin looking for some customizable
companionship fellas you'll love the
mannequin fully posable she'll change
her features based on your desire and if
you love the yandere types you'll love
the fact that she'll attack any woman
who comes close to her item 978 the
desire camera having a hard time
figuring out what you really want from
life having trouble finding out what
your loved ones want for their birthday
want to get some grade a blackmail
material on someone in your life this is
the product for you item 1918
tic-tac-toe sick of video games want
something more intense and immersive
than even vr want to give your kids a
new playmate then tic-tac-toe is exactly
what you need set them up in your house
and the game will never end item 131 the
ipods these adorable little doodads make
great friends for your pets and they'll
also keep a close eye on your house when
you're not around they come in two
colors and they're sure to lift up your
mood just by being there item 407 the
song of genesis are you a keen gardener
who wants to grow plants the likes of
which humanity has never seen this
little cassette will turn your garden
into its own little slice of eden in no
time flat note out of stock due to
supply chain tampering item 1370
pesterbot a little toy with a big
personality perfect for any retro toy
collector or kids with aspirations to
become evil geniuses pesterbot is the
ultimate hilarious playmate item 348 a
gift for dad need a warm meal that will
really soothe your soul forget standard
hot plates this plate will give you a
soup so delicious it'll repair your
relationship with your dearly departed
father and give you the inner peace
you've been so desperately seeking
item085 hand drawn cassie the ideal gift
for any art lover you won't find a
drawing more filled with life than this
one and that's a guarantee let cassie
make a new home on your living room wall
item 1609 the remains of a chair once an
extremely comfortable chair that would
appear behind you whenever you really
needed it to take the weight off your
feet now discontinue due to slight
damages sustained in transit item 666
spirit lodge got an addiction you need
to kick booze pills cigarettes video
games youtube videos if you think rehab
is too expensive and aaa is too
condescending then buy yourself your
very own spirit lodge the perfect way to
go cold turkey item 323 when to go skull
do you need to do some precious protein
loading for your upcoming workout
regimen then this stylish piece of
algonquin headwear will boost your
appetite and make light work of that new
carnivorous diet item 136 naked doll
you've got to do the best to please her
just cause she's a living doll that's
right this product will have you saying
hello dolly as she floats towards you in
the nude she's definitely going to
provoke some strong emotional reactions
in you item 261 pan-dimensional vending
machine the perfect vending machine for
your home or office if you like real
surprises mind blowing and sometimes
head exploding snacks drinks and treats
from all over the multiverse comes out
of this handy dandy little machine note
you are liable for checking allergy
information item 2295 the bear with a
heart of patchwork if you don't have
health insurance this little bear can be
a genuine lifesaver skip those annoying
organ donation waiting lists and get
right down to business with this
patchwork pal item 426 i am a toaster i
am an excellent four-slice toaster with
user-friendly settings and energy
efficiency that makes me both affordable
to use and more environmentally friendly
you will appreciate having me in your
kitchen item 1123 atrocity skull are you
a big fan of the darker side of history
but find that photos books and archival
footage aren't enough for you this
tasteful knickknack will help you get in
touch with living history like never
before item 2430 immortal hitler clone
if you're jewish romani gay transgender
disabled polish french russian mentally
ill or just not a terrible person then
the immortal hitler clone will make the
perfect stress-reducing punching bag for
you item 387 living lego everything is
awesome when you've got your hands on
the living lego the only building block
toy that can play back and they're
completely harmless unless you step on
them item 137 a real toy if you are a
toy collector or a kid who doesn't seem
to have many friends then a real toy
will enhance any and every playing
experience see your games come to life
like never before nothing beats playing
with a real toy item 272 and old iron
nail want to keep something in place
with zero risk of escape as long as it
has a shadow then the old iron nail has
got you covered even has a built-in
security system to keep itself safe from
any attempts to damage it item 4158 big
charlie if you love to grill then you'll
love big charlie this mighty steer will
keep you swimming in stakes forever
perfect for hosting barbecues for
literally everyone you know and everyone
they know item 3108 the nerfing gun are
other people's things nicer than yours
that ain't right get your hands on the
nerfing gun and knock those jerks down a
peg for good professor snyder couldn't
believe what he was reading this was
textbook anomalous insanity it even had
hardcover copies of all the books we
were complaining about during the intro
it didn't take long for the official scp
sales catalog to be designated an
anomaly itself with the number
scp-00j but if you can believe it the
madness didn't even stop there you see
the catalog didn't just contain the
anomalies themselves as available
products it also contained a wide
variety of scp foundation merchandise
t-shirts books dvds even video games and
action figures and so much more
naturally none of this had ever been
authorized by the scp foundation itself
or the staff or anomalies in question to
give you an idea of just how absurd this
gets here are some examples of the fresh
scp foundation merch inside the sales
catalog there was a white cotton t-shirt
with a slogan on it reading i survived
the wrath of scp-682
along with a picture of scp-682 on the
shirt itself available in size small to
extra extra extra large a 30.48
centimeter or 12-inch
scp-076-2 action figure with
interchangeable wardrobe accessories and
carrying case shaped like scp-076-1
when the real abel was shown a picture
of this action figure he responded to it
with disgust claiming it was an insult
though to be fair able to think that
about a lot of things a 2-disc cd titled
dr kleff's holiday hits cover depicts dr
alto clef in a santa outfit and holding
a microphone when he was questioned
about it dr cleft denied ever recording
such an album he had only recorded a
brief ukulele lp with no vocals back in
1991. there was also a somewhat
tasteless woman's pinup calendar called
the girls of scp featuring you know what
no this one this one is just creepy
moving on there was a three-disc dvd set
entitled scp brawl the greatest scp
versus scp fights the cover depicts
scp-076-2 173 and 682. each disc is nine
hours long and features various ketter
level scps fighting each other we've
actually been releasing segments of it
on this channel for months now and we
intend to keep doing it no matter how
many cease and desist letters we keep
getting from the official scp sales
catalog there was also the 2-disc
soundtrack for ferdinand the musical a
musical about the life of scp-082
which seems to contain some tracks with
the vocals of scp-082 himself when asked
about this scp-082 spoke with great
pride about his time in musical theater
but given that he's a pathological liar
it's difficult to know whether this is
true he's the current owner of the album
because he ate the last owner and
refuses to give it back oh and there was
also an adorable high quality scp-999
plushie incidentally this is the only
one of these products you can get in
real life from www.scpswag.com
no we're not kidding check out the link
in the description after the video this
whole anomaly ended up being a deeply
bizarre mystery for the members of scp
foundation personnel to investigate
while you could theoretically order
multiple iterations of each item you
would only get the real one surrounded
by a number of cheap copies while
professor snyder called the help point
directly he was repeatedly rebuffed with
the call operator hanging up on him if
you try to do anything other than order
an item if you do order an item it will
simply end up on your doorstep and then
the foundation will need to come and
recontain it personnel wishing to test
this item are required to do so using
their personal funds as it's essentially
just throwing foundation money into a
furnace there currently only seems to be
one of these catalogs but if ever one
appears elsewhere it's likely to give
the scp foundation a major headache see
what do we tell you books you just can't
trust them do you want our advice just
stick to youtube videos in fact you
should go check out why everyone wants
to eat this corpse as cp 1176 and
scp-049 boiled scrambled and fried
plagued dr tail for more bizarre and
hilarious journeys into scp foundation
more